bam margera's life has had its ups and
downs and we're not talking about
skateboarding from hidden sex tapes to
tumultuous relationships this is the
untold truth of bam margera
margera's future as a daredevil seemed
set in stone from an early age as a
child he's said to have picked up the
habit of running straight into walls and
jumping off coffee tables in his family
home his grandfather having witnessed
this self-destructive behavior on
several occasions started to call him
bam bam which was eventually shortened
to ban the name stuck and after he
became known to millions through his
bone-crunching exploits on mtv he
decided to make it his legal name but
after completing all of the necessary
paperwork he had second thoughts about
filing it he was ultimately persuaded by
his father phil to remain legally at
least brandon cole margera
bam may not be royalty but he is the
king of his castle well sort of after
his work on tv earned him enough cash to
make his dream home a reality margera
purchased a gothic style mansion in his
home state of pennsylvania and
re-christened it castle bam adding a
host of new features to the property to
make himself and his crew of
co-conspirators more comfortable the
additions included a pirate-themed bar a
treetop casino that margera and his
friends later destroyed with cannonballs
and of course a huge skatepark
before the jackass crew formed up
margera filmed and edited his own video
series with his friends from the cky
crew the name stands for camp kill
yourself which is also the name of
margera's older brother jess's band the
latest and greatest was the last
installment in the cult video series
though it was the first one made after
marjera hit the mainstream meaning that
he had access to equipment that was
previously too expensive the production
value saw a marked improvement from
previous cky offerings though it wasn't
the shiny new look of the film that had
fans talking on some copies of the dvd
margera decided to include a clip of
himself and his then fiancee having sex
as an easter egg hidden at the end of
the movie
margera was admitted to chester county
hospital with nasty head injuries on
june 12 2010 after an altercation
outside his suburban nightclub the note
left him bleeding and unconscious on the
pavement the incident took place when
westchester resident elizabeth ray whose
home shares a wall with margera's club
saw the jackass star leave the premises
for a cigarette at around 2am and
decided to confront him about the noise
that had been keeping her awake things
escalated very quickly according to
margera's friend tammy palumbo palumbo
who was with margero when the attack
reportedly took place claims he walked
away from the argument thinking it was
over when rey cracked him over the back
of the head with a pipe-like object rey
is said to have continued her attack
verbally as palumbo cradled margera's
gashed and bloodied head supposedly
yelling quote i'll hit him again and
i'll make sure i kill him next time
margera's concussion meant he had to
miss the shooting of the epic final
scene in the jackass 3d movie in the end
rey was found guilty of aggravated
assault and reckless endangerment she
was spared prison time however with
margera himself urging the district
attorney to allow rey to serve her time
on probation after learning that she was
a caregiver for her housebound mother
after being hitched as a part of the tv
show bam's unholy union margera and
missy rothstein ended their so-called
unholy union in 2012 five years after
getting hitched in front of millions of
viewers on their mtv show margera didn't
have to wait too long to give marriage a
second shot tying the knot with nicole
boyd in 2013 during the random hero
festival an event he held in reykjavik
iceland in honor of his late friend ryan
dunn it was far from a fairytale
icelandic wedding however with the
former jackass star spending the evening
performing with his band face
unstoppable margera's wedding attire was
equally unorthodox he chose to walk down
the makeshift isle wearing a hoodie
along with something mtv described as
some kind of modified skeletor costume
from one memorable experience at an
icelandic music festival to another
margera would sooner forget in 2015
videos emerged of him being attacked by
rappers gistly palmy and eagle tiny
thorarenson in the backstage area of the
secret solstice festival with the
prominent icelandic rappers landing
several punches on margera before he was
pulled away and fell to the ground
according to a video that margera
recorded shortly after the assault the
musicians allegedly set about him at the
behest of leon hill margera's former
head of digital marketing and the
current secret solstice marketing
director margera claimed hill owed him
money and accused him of fudging the
numbers on his youtube channel hill
however responded to the allegations
with a statement of his own that
detailed the series of events leading to
the fight which he claims margera
instigated in the statement hill blames
the lack of good material from argera's
youtube channel underperforming
the tragic death of ryan dunn
understandably changed margera's life
forever the extent to which it impacted
marjera was made painfully clear when he
made his return to reality tv in 2016
appearing alongside his mother april on
the vh1 series family therapy with dr
jen during the interview margera
admitted to drinking to forget rather
than for the fun of it and revealed he'd
struggled with suicidal thoughts and
depression april margera who has
appeared numerous times in her son's
various videos and tv shows over the
years was reduced to tears as she
recounted a christmas argument in which
her son told her he would die before her
likely by drowning in his own swimming
pool
margera's time in the family therapy
house led to him getting sober for the
first time in his adult life spurred on
by the support of dr jen mann and bam's
mother april after the show wrapped
margera managed to go four months
without a drink though he fell off the
wagon while attending an art show in a
follow-up interview with vh1 april
revealed that her son slip was
orchestrated by one of his friends who
offered him a can of coke that was
actually full of booze despite the
setback she insisted that margera is
still trying to stay sober and was
considering entering himself into rehab
skater died dude i just stopped i was
like i'd rather skate
in early 2017 words surfaced that
margera was back on the skateboard after
a lengthy layoff that as he later
explained in an interview with gen chem
magazine stemmed from an assortment of
problems including bone spurs in his
feet the pressures of his celebrity
status in the skating community and the
knowledge that he couldn't safely skate
until he dealt with his drinking problem
finding himself on an editing job in
estonia during the dark of winter he
felt himself reached the end of his rope
and felt the urge to get to barcelona
for the sake of going skating he got on
a plane bought a new board and hooked up
with his friend fellow skater and
barcelona resident thomas winkle who
promptly started filming margera's
exploits
i rented a car and we just went went
from town to town meeting up with the
locals and skating everything
if that sounds like a nice vacation well
it probably was but it wasn't all fun
and games margera's skating holiday
served a larger purpose by helping him
stay sober for a while at least as he
confessed in the interview with jenkum
it's been a real struggle for me to stay
off the alcohol but just as long you're
surrounded by good people and you have
something to do you'll be good i know
being in spain is the best place for me
right now to not drink
van margera managed to get sober and
rediscover his love of skateboarding
during his time in beautiful barcelona
but addiction reared its ugly head once
more when he returned to the united
states in january 2018 the famous
daredevil got hit with a dui in
california officers noticed him using
his phone at the wheel and smelled
alcohol on his breath after pulling him
over for questioning speaking to page
six his mother april margera begged for
understanding saying don't be so quick
to judge other people everybody has a
different story and everybody is going
through different things it's not an
instant fix margera checked into rehab
for a third time following the dui
arrest for which he got probation
telling his instagram followers that he
was quote hoping the term third time as
a charm is true sadly another relapse
was just around the corner as the
one-time daredevil turned to alcohol
once more after being robbed in colombia
after arriving in cartagena alone he
claimed he got into a taxi at the
airport and then things got scary
i couldn't speak spanish they couldn't
speak english and they translated on
their phone for me to read
empty your wallet as they put a gun on
their lap
margera said he handed over 500 and was
let go he described the incident as
quote weird
bam margera was reportedly fired from
the fourth jackass film after allegedly
failing to adhere to a so-called
wellness agreement that required him to
stay sober among other conditions during
the production of the film after his
firing from the project margera filed a
lawsuit which threatened to derail the
release of the fourth jackass movie
johnny knoxville who was named in the
lawsuit told variety in an interview
that the whole affair with bam was
heartbreaking he explained we wanted him
all throughout the movie but
unfortunately that's not the way it
worked out i love bam we all love bam
he's our brother you know you just hope
that he takes it upon himself to get the
help that he needs because we all care
about him a lot
things quickly went from bad to worse
after bam margera was given the boot
from jackass forever jeff tremaine one
of the masterminds behind the franchise
and the director of the fourth jackass
film got a restraining order against his
former friend after he began threatening
him and his family legal documents seen
by people revealed bam's behavior to
remain alleged left him in great fear
for his and his family's personal safety
he told the courts adding that margera
said quote that he has powers as a
wizard and can create and strike
lightning while speaking at times using
numbers instead of english the judge
ordered marjara to stay away from
tremaine and his family for three years
some of the drama played out on social
media for the world to see when margera
said that his former friends had
betrayed abandoned and rejected him
jackass alum stevo chimed in to defend
the people he was accusing responding to
margera on social media stevo wrote bam
the two people you're saying wronged you
knoxville and tremaine are the same two
people who organized the intervention
which saved my life everyone bent over
backwards to get you in the movie and
all you had to do was not get loaded we
all love you every bit as much as we all
say we do but nobody who really loves
you can enable or encourage you to stay
sick
in december 2017 just two days before
christmas bam margera's wife nikki gave
birth to a son phoenix wolf margera in
september 2021 news broke that nikki
filed court documents asking for full
custody of their son it seems as though
the relationship fell apart following
bam's experience with addiction but
nikki doesn't appear to have given up on
him just yet tmz noted that though she
filed for custody she did not also file
for divorce which is uncommon according
to the gossip site nikki wants bam to be
able to visit their son with a monitor
present according to tmz nikki is happy
for bam to pick his own monitor but she
will have to approve of that person
first for all his troubles bam clearly
adores his son who appears regularly in
his instagram feed hopefully bam and fam
can get beyond the hard times if you or
someone you know is struggling with
addiction please call the substance
abuse and mental health administration's
24 7 national helpline at 1-800-662-help
that's 1-800-662-4357